it was the margate carnival
we were trying to thread our way through
traffic
strapped down in an ambulance in labour
with a sense of dread that something was
going wrong
helen knew instinctively the baby she
was carrying inside her was in grave
danger
i remember hearing her heart rate
dipping on the monitor
and
having a really strong sense of what
that meant
staff at the queen elizabeth the queen
mother hospital delivered baby harriet
by emergency c-section eight days later
she died her brain had been starved of
oxygen due to a catastrophic failure of
care
that was amongst the most intimate
moments of
of
our lives with her because
because that was when she was no longer
strapped to monitors when there was so
little help that could be given to her
the nhs in england is short of around 2
000 midwives but the ochenton report
into some 200 baby deaths in shrewsbury
and telford has found other reasons for
a widespread failure in nhs maternity
care
it uncovered a toxic work culture and
blamed a focus on natural birth without
medical intervention as a factor in
babies and mothers dying or suffering
avoidable complications
not referring women appropriately of
intervention has needed came from the
organization and targets around reducing
caesarean sections and what happens then
is that the wrong decision-making then
starts to happen
the ochenton report investigated some
1600 allegations of poor maternity care
at the shrewsbury and telford hospital
nhs trust
and the east kent trust where helen gave
birth is undergoing its own independent
inquiry
concerns have also been raised about
standards at trusts in harrow basildon
nottingham sheffield and morkum
the government has pledged to make
changes
to all the families that have suffered
so greatly
i am
sorry
the report clearly shows that you were
failed by a service that was there to
help you and your loved ones to bring
life into this world
we will make the changes that the report
says are needed at both a local and
national level
that apology from the health secretary
will be the first for many bereaved
families
do you think
if your concerns had been addressed and
the right medical interventions
had taken place that harriet would still
be alive today
yeah i do
i think she'd be
a seven-year-old girl
and
there was no reason for her to die
ashish joshi
skynews